[Music]
chuck i got another explainer video for
you
all right yeah these don't come out of
nowhere because i could you know
if they were just wiki pages i'd say go
to the wiki page you know i gotta it's
got to be something you're not getting
anywhere else
okay i like that i like that take that
wiki page
you know i love wiki especially my
people
have some of the best i don't mean to
boast but my people
we have some of the best wiki pages out
there you read a wiki page on anything
in the universe it's going to be well
written it's going to be nicely
illustrated
and i i'm very proud of my general
astrophysics community for our wiki
pages
okay you look up the venus the moon
black holes
you know expanding universe just check
it out it's all good it's all good
so i got one for you ready go ahead that
rocks are light
you mean pebbles no rocks
as in rocks little tv boulders i don't
care i don't care what size
i'm okay they're all light but what i
mean by light is that they're low
density
now you might say no they're not yeah
i was gonna say okay hercules
well we went over weight and density on
another explainer yes right it did which
we could say a big tree is heavy
but you but it floats okay so how heavy
could it be if it floats
all right so the battleship floats
battleship floats so the average density
of a battleship or
even an aircraft carrier is less than
water because when you do a
cross-section through an aircraft
carrier
it's mostly air okay okay
most of a ship is ever air and so that's
why great
discovery by the way to realize you can
make a boat out of something that itself
the material doesn't flow float right
you have to it's the design of the whole
bit
i guarantee you that guy
was not well received no but what he did
with it transformed
naval warfare you didn't have to make a
ship out of wood anymore you can make it
out of steel
just put enough hole in there and and
you're good so god that would have been
cool to be on the first steel
battleship going up against wooden dudes
yeah you would just plow through that
that's called asymmetric advantage in
warfare
nice okay i like that yeah so the first
person with a gun when all you have is a
bow and arrow
asymmetric advantage okay that's also
called winner
the winner you won that battle okay
if you're there with a bow and arrow and
somebody's shooting you down he's okay
we're good
we good that's like like aliens with ray
guns
and you're up there with a pistol
shooting at it's like no can you just
see the situation here
i am so glad you said that because i
hate
when they do that where in the movie
when the movies when the earthlings go
up against the aliens and the earthlings
are shooting bullets and the aliens are
shooting like laser beams laser beams
that vaporize their homes right and i'm
like
really come back and we win come
on come on all right
butter brought a pistol to a laser fight
get out all right
back to rocks rocks are dense or not
dense
no they're light they're light now
here's why earth was once molten
okay when in the early days of formation
right when you're molten
and you're as big as the earth right
gravity will do things to that molten
mixture
okay that makes sense right so so
you if you're denser
if you're heavier if you're denser you
will sink to the middle
right that makes sense if you're lighter
you'll float this happens with any
if you're mixing oil and vinegar for
your salad um
okay you're mixing anything layered
cocktails
for example and the generally well
always
the lower density stuff will float on
top of the higher density stuff
some things you can mix and it'll stay
mixed for a while that's cool
but that's how things work okay
so why is it
that when you walk around earth's
surface
you find rocks
okay earth does not have rocks in its
core
you know what it has in its core iron
iron nickel
right magnesium right okay it's got
heavy metals in its core
because all the heavy stuff sank to the
middle
and all the light stuff floated to the
top
so earth's crust where the active
ingredient
is rock is the lightest stuff
in earth when it formed
so the oh sorry sorry sorry it's the
third lightest
it's the third lightest third light the
very lightest stuff are the gases
okay okay so they're floating over your
head right okay okay
and next is the water okay all right
okay
so the water sank to the bottom of the
gas
makes sense okay that's earth's surface
all right and what sinks to the bottom
of the water
rocks rocks and what sinks below the
rocks all the rest of the crap that
earth is made of that's heavier than the
rocks
so rocks are the third lightest thing
that came about in the creation of the
earth
yes basically basically and it's made
our crust
now everything didn't solidify in the
same instant
okay so and plus you have volcanoes that
communicate lower layers with upper
layers and things
so there is some of this but that's why
if you're looking for iron you got to
find the iron ore
okay the iron or what
you know exactly i'm sorry i had to do
it i
had to do it it was so bad but it was
bad
it was so bad it was good okay i know it
was so bad it was good
okay so there's iron ore nickel or so
so it's not everywhere there are these
places where these
these veins had been preserved
at the point earth was solidifying
okay so you get this remnants of the
stuff
you want to find out where most of the
iron is and most of the nickel is on
earth
it is in the center of the earth and the
universe has a lot of nickel and iron in
it
so earth got it's plenty of its share of
those two ingredients
and it's in our core and you might say
well how you know you've never been
there let me hear it
well how do you know you've never been
there well i like that accent you
brought that
that that was the obnoxious yeah that
was in the classroom
how do you know mr astrophysicist
so we have geophysicists who anytime
there's an earthquake
right they can time the
passage of the of the
um of the earthquake signals through the
different layers of the earth
and depending on where and when they
receive them at other stations
they can map the density profile
of the entire earth they know it
because because the the wave moves
through dense materials differently
through from light materials and once
you know that you can figure that out
and bada bing
we've got an iron core that's amazing
there you have it so
so we think we're about the density of
water all right approximately some
people float some people think
that right humans are about the density
of water so
so we think of rocks as heavy and
relative to us they're heavy relative to
water they're heavy relative to air
but not relative to the rest of the
earth that's why you don't have to
have a mining operation to find rocks
[Laughter]
they're sticking out of the side of the
mountain they have floated to the top
loaded to the top and they're they're
there for the taking
and by the way that's why it's so hard
to find meteorites
on earth's surface because most
meteorites
are rocky and so the land
and it just looks like any other rock so
you got to go to places where they would
stand out
and there are two kinds of places where
that happens one is the desert
sandy desert sand one problem is that
sand
will cover it over often however sand
will also blow away and
if you see a rock sitting in the middle
because you can ski you can scan
like many square miles at a pop okay
so you say oh there's something sticking
out of the sand over there that just got
revealed
it's probably a meteorite wow okay hey b
another place you can go is um glacier
ice sheets
in antarctica and in greenland so most
meteorites in the col
in our collections in our modern
collections come from greenland and
antarctica for just that reason because
every other place on earth is made of
freaking rocks
right so there there's probably tons of
them there but they're just hanging out
of the rocks because
some people ask how come all the
meteorites are aiming for antarctica
right or that's like that's like the
thing
um how come i only find my car keys near
the lamppost
right at night right well
because that's the only place you would
have seen them right
okay but we're good wow that was cool
man it's a rockstar rockstar
rocks are light people and is even
lighter
because it's got air in it air is
helping it out yeah that's the
that's the fast uh solidifying rock from
a volcano when it hits the ocean
it's also great for taking dead skin off
your feet but
no i don't want to jump that's
yes that's why god put limits on this
world exactly man that's
the best that's the best use of it never
mind that god could have made it so that
you never got
rough feet in the first place okay
i didn't perfect that that foot thing
let me give you something else to help
that okay
that's the second round of creation
right okay
yes exactly the first round was you know
the
the the the actual body and the second
round was cosmetics
for those days where even god couldn't
help you right
first like i can't even do anything with
this
here take some pumice take some of this
other stuff right you do it l'oreal baby
i can't help you need max factor i
cannot help you you need oil of old age
[Laughter]
all right all right that was that was an
explainer i'm just saying rocks are life
that's all you got it star talk
explainer video
you're the grass tyson keep looking
[Music]